the discriminant what's the discriminant
about it because quadratic equations are
haters and they discriminate against you
know look why though they the
discriminant is about discriminate
between different kinds of quadratic
functions right so so understand what
the screen is you've got to come back to
you
code right formula okay so quadratic
formula tells you for any given
quadratic equation that is in general
form okay you can express its roots in
this way and you guys have learnt this
formula to death now this equation will
tell you the roots of the equation okay
you know for quadratics we expect to but
there aren't always two there might be
one or there might be none okay
now you can see the important part of
this equation the part that tells you
whether there's zero or one or not is
this part that's sitting underneath the
square root sign okay and that's why we
call this the discriminant
so we denote it by the special sine
Delta okay so if Delta is equal to if
the discriminant is equal to V squared
minus 4a see when we know the value of
Delta what does that tell us about the
number of roots well listen guys if
Delta art were negative okay for the
discriminant was less than zero what
would happen to the quadratic formula
okay
well cuz you've got a negative number
underneath the square root this thing
kind of explodes because you can't get
values down there at least not real
values values in graph okay so if the
discriminant is less than zero what that
implies is you have no real roots okay
okay sometimes you'll see it written the
Internet's it's sort of strange they'll
still sometimes say that means you've
got unreal roots because strictly
speaking there are roots is just that
they involve complex numbers are numbers
that aren't real right but I think this
is a little more traditional way to say
and if you've never seen that
funny-looking are before which has two
lines along the vertical line that's
just the set notation simply alright so
that's if the discriminant is negative
if the discriminant is just equal to
zero just pull on zero okay you can see
what happens here right you have X being
equal to minus B plus or minus zero
right
whatever - right so don't forget - be on
to a that's your axis right the axis of
symmetry of the parabola so it's like
the middle and this plus or minus is how
far you go on either side to get to the
root it's good symmetrical right so that
far and that far okay well if you're
going C you're a distance you've only
got one room and it's at the axis of
symmetry okay so you would say one real
root
okay so just go to the lesser zero just
humans evil to zero for last cases if
the discriminant is greater than zero
and that's the case that we're normally
used to dealing with right like if you
have the square root of five
okay this is if you like zero roots one
root so you would expect it to have two
roots two real roots okay
now let's pause before we go any further
when we say one real root here right so
a situation you're looking at something
like say y equals x squared and it's
just sitting find the axis right well we
keep on talking about it's a quadratic
in our two roots right so sometimes
you'll see this set as not one real root
but two equal roots I like saying unreal
roots that's a less common way to say it
it's it's like two roots on the same
spot okay but it's equally valid right
by the same token having to be routier
what I really mean is there was in
different spots okay so sometimes you'll
hear that set as two distinct roots okay
so I prove that K must have some value
for the roots to be distinct that means
in terms of the limit okay
now underneath this some part here if
the discriminant is positive there's a
special case I mentioned to some of
slowly just now that is if the
discriminant is a perfect square alright
so if the discriminant is K squared
where K is an integer
in other words if K is a very square
okay so case in every sphere what
happened well case like 25 or 64 or a
hundred right when it goes underneath
the square root here you can evaluate
the square root right so instead of the
square root of 25 dude by five or
instead of square root 64 you divide
eight okay so you won't have any square
root anymore it will vanish okay so we
know sirs
so if the discriminant is a square
number um you get what we call rational
roots
this means rational roots because you
don't have any of these sir to these
irrational values in there right so
sometimes they'll say tell me what
values of what those a B and T must have
I'm in order for the roots of this
equation to be rational okay one last
thing before we leave the discriminant
instead of looking at the positive case
let's look at the negative case if the
quadratic equation has no roots right
that means it's either always above the
axis or always below okay so it's a
situation like this always above or it's
always below because it can't cross
because it has no real roots right so we
give these two different things on
particular names because sometimes
they're physically or geometrically
important to us right so since this one
up here is always positive right that
means you can take any value and it'll
be definitely positive I can guarantee R
absence would be definitely positive if
we call it positive definite on the
other hand if it's the other one if it's
always below the axis if any value take
it are we definitely negative then we
call it negative definite
now in both these cases here you've got
a discriminant less than zero right so
what's the decisive factor that tells
you whether it's facing up or facing
down which which number in the quadratic
equation defines yeah it's it's this
coefficient isn't it
the leading coefficient if you remember
that from the United ok that a if it's
like 1 or minus 2 or whatever it'll tell
you whether it's concave up or concave
down right so if a is positive
it'll be concave up and if a is negative
it'll be concave down a bit maybe you've
done ok it's pretty much all the things
you need to know about the destroyer or
just so